right the only person here that has a
kind of experience in a state that's
been probably at the top in the country
for corruption when it comes down to
elections going all the way back to the
mobs involvement Kennedy yeah more
governors in your state have gone to
jail than I think any other state and
you you said earlier yourself you went
for eight years as well because of
something about you know how you there
was a negotiation on the call in the
record we've already talked about that
on the last podcast
yeah yeah so so you you went and against
the most powerful Democrat who was out
there campaigning the last two weeks
which was Barack Obama there's not a
Democrat more powerful than Obama right
now right minus the guys that are
putting the money George Soros but as
far as the voice goes right is Barack
Obama how much of what you listening to
Adam and Ricky going back and forth and
you were a Democratic governor it's very
important for people to know that how
much credibility is there on the
gamesmanship on the manipulation on all
that stuff going behind closed doors
look I really appreciated that
conversation with spirited and it really
was a microcosm of America Adam yeah 100
and that certainly emotion the anger the
energy involved in it all kind of really
highlights the divisions in our country
and I think it goes down to fundamental
trust I'm not going to belabor the point
I didn't break a law across the line or
take a penny it was a corrupt
prosecution I would have never believed
that had it not happened to me you think
those are the good guys they would look
for the law and do the law and that
makes stuff up or lie or cover up
evidence having said that I had to go
through all of that I'm finally home
look to the future I believe the best
thing this new Republican house can do
for our country Democrats and
Republicans to restore trust is we've
got to have election Integrity to such
an extent that the American people can
believe in the process they have very
real reasons not to believe in it I
don't know who won or who Biden was
declared the winner I don't want to
relitigate all of that but the fact is a
lot of people don't think that was a
fair game do I believe uh fraud exists
vote fraud and cheating and elections I
know it as a fact coming out of Chicago
politics ticks I also know it spending
six years in Congress and hearing
stories about the Democrats from
Philadelphia and Detroit and other big
cities now do Republicans steal votes in
places where they control uh polling the
apparatus I'm sure they do it's human
nature we've got to fix this system the
Democrats go out and run save democracy
democracies at stake I think in this
past election that's projection let's
see if they really want to save
democracy if the Republicans are willing
to put the country first past something
like guidelines to dictate to states
that they got to do certain things like
Florida did and Georgia did to clean up
their electoral process I think that's
probably the best service that they can
do for our country and in the long run
it's going to save our democracy I
predict the Democrats will characterize
it as something other than what it is if
the Republicans even do it and you'll
see gridlock because
they have a different parties have a
vested interest in how certain things
are right is it fair to say the
criticism Democrats give to the right is
the way they manipulate elections is
through gerrymandering and that's kind
of what they specialize in yes and the
criticism Republicans will give the left
is they do election fraud and that's
kind of how they do it to win elections
so it's like hey if you're going to do
Gerry Manor we're going to do this but
if you're going to do this we're going
to do that is that a fair criticism that
eat side gives to the other side I think
to varying degrees they're both guilty
of that because I think the Republicans
more so on the gerrymandering right I
think Democrats more so on the stealing
votes but let me tell you Republicans in
places that they control stuff and no
one's looking human nature and being
what it is they're taking some votes too
it's how it is it's sort of built in to
the system it should be fixed it must be
fixed so we can trust our country and
our democracy because through the hard
experience I've been through and you can
think I'm full of [ __ ] and that I did
the things they said I did I didn't they
were legal every one of them Obama
Started they came to me to make a
political deal we had conversations he
went to the White House they threw my
ass into the [ __ ] and I wouldn't
give in I keep fighting to this day
because of the last senate seat right
there was a senate which was ultimately
reversed by the Appellate Court that can
never uphold that standard because that
was a political deal Obama wanted to
make with me and they put me there for
fundraising I didn't break that law
either but having said that so I learned
lessons you can't really by the way for
some people that are not familiar you
were a star that was coming up that
would have ran for presidency some
people even looked at you as you have a
very big upside that it wasn't just
about Governor for you and that's kind
of what was going on and you guys are
both from the same stage so it's a lot
of competition they're going on as well
I was the first Democrat government 26
years in Illinois which is a microcosm
of America at the time was the fifth
largest state I think it's sixth now we
have everything in Illinois like the
United States and I was sort of like the
new face on the Block and there were
some people that were speculating Obama
came two years later we both knew each
other in the state legislature he has
great skill and talent life is how it is
sometimes it doesn't go your way having
said that here we are look into the
future I think this new house Republican
majority however small it might be or
not as big as they had expected it was
going to be I do think that resolving
the way we do elections and pushing the
states to have some sort of rules that
they have to follow because we have
those for federal crimes these mandates
that federal laws have why not do it for
these elections so we can have elections
in other states like they had in Florida
like they have in Georgia now because
they fixed what was wrong in Florida
that have now made it where people trust
the system toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]